[Musique]
françois bayrou bonjour merci d'être
avec nous au commissaire au plan
maire de pau patron du modem j'ai envie
de commencer alors je vais vous parler
évidemment du covin mais je vais vous
parler aussi de votre prophète de votre
réflexion je dirais c'est une réflexion
sur la démographie en france c'est très
intéressant et j'y consacrerai la
deuxième partie de cet entretien mais
françois bayrou je voudrais commencer
sur l'autorité de l'état
pourquoi violences contre les forces de
l'ordre les pompiers
les enseignants les élus rapporte
dégradé de l'exécutif avec une partie de
l'armée trafic de stupéfiants au grand
jour montée du communautarisme est ce
que l'état
françois bayrou n'a plus d'autorité nous
sommes dans une société qui est
profondément déstabilisé et l'état n'a
pas changé renouveler ces pratiques
l'état n'a pas trouvé les voies les
moyens l'organisation nécessaire pour
faire face
alors évidemment ça a failli non je ne
veux pas employer ce genre de mots parce
qu'il est excessif il laisserait croire
que c'est de la faute 2 ce n'est pas mon
poil emmanuel macron mon eau non sa
ferme et ça fait 30 ans que que cette
dégradation est en cours trente ans que
toutes vos émissions oui à peu près
comment sur des sujets de cet ordre est
donc le la réflexion que nous devons
avoir c'est est ce qu'on peut trouver
une organisation qui fasse que l'état
soit présent et respectez vous dites
l'éducation vous avez raison de dire
c'est pas l'état qui est mis en cause
dans l'éducation c'est le lien entre la
famille et l'école c'est le lien entre
les enfants et le quartier dans lequel
ils vivent
le la réflexion que nous devons avoir
elle doit prendre en compte cette
réalité qui me frappe depuis longtemps
et qui est le on est au bout d'une
situation qui est une situation qui dure
et qui s'est aggravée depuis des années
et on doit maintenant faire preuve de
cette volonté de cette imagination
nécessaires pour en sortir alors l'état
l'autorité de l'état sera le fil rouge
de tout cette rencontre que nous avons
ce matin françois bayrou pourquoi parce
que je vais prendre un autre exemple on
parle beaucoup de la police actuellement
demain il ya une grande manifestation un
rassemblement ce sera pagne un
rassemblement devant l'assemblée
nationale pour la première fois toutes
les forces politiques à l'exception de
la france un soumises toutes les forces
politiques seront devant l'assemblée
nationale ce que vous y serez
c'est possible que j'y passe oui en
effet ce gérant et est-ce que c'est
l'argent et et gérald darmanin avec les
policiers dans un grand rassemblement
franches on vous voyait bien que ça a
quelque chose d'inédit
oui donc probablement qu'il veut
exprimer quelque chose et on voit bien
ce qu'il veut exprimer ce que nous avons
tous besoin d'exprimer tous les
parlementaires qui seront là au contact
avec les policiers
les policiers nous protège et on a le
sentiment que personne ne les protègent
eux et le le nombre de d'interpellations
le nombre de réflexions qui sont faites
le nombre de mises en cause le
le le ciblage le fait qu'ils ont
l'impression qu'entre justice et police
les choses ne vont pas dans le même sens
et que celui que vous arrêtez la veille
vous le retrouvez le lendemain 7
cette rupture de la société oui nous en
sommes tous responsables et nous en
sommes tous comptables et il faut donc
que nous ayons le courage en effet de
l'assumer alors je ne sais pas si c'est
par une wii manifestation par un
rassemblement par la présence d'un
ministre que ça ce que ça se joue ça se
joue aussi jean jacques bourdin sur vos
plateaux la manière dont assez souvent
c'est pas une mise en cause non non non
mais la manière dont elle accepte aussi
souvent les images qui ont été publiées
à longueur de semaines et de mois donne
le sentiment que la police est dans un
rapport de brutalité avec avec des
citoyens et ce n'est pas vrai ils sont
ils essaient de maintenir l'ordre que ce
qu'ils ont en face d'eux veulent
détruire parce que c'est ça le but de
l'oeil de ses opérations
je vous parle de l'autorité de l'état
encore une fois avec la décision par
exemple de jean castex suppression du
corps préfectoral tout en conservant
évidemment la fonction de préfet mais
c'est une révolution aussi n'est-ce vous
voyez c'est une erreur ou pas n'ont
cessé poser la question alors vous voyez
essayez de vous mettre à la place de
ceux qui vous écoute
allez-y dit suppression du corps
préfectoral c'est une norme dessus
présent lors les ceux qui vous écoutent
pense que les préfets vont dix pages et
10 tout en conservant la fonderie en de
ses biens non mais je sais c'est un blog
de foot jeux wii le débat public
oui bon qu'est-ce qui se passe oui est
ce qu'il ya un français qui peut venir
en face de moi et de houla en ce moment
et dire monsieur l'état ça marche bien
l'êta en france
il fait son travail l'état marche bien
serrer les dents ne marche pas enfants
de l'état ne marche pas depuis des
décennies il ya eu
une lente dégradation l'état normalement
il devrait être en soutien de la société
et on l'a organisée alors c'est une
tragédie parce que les gens qui sont qui
occupe ces fonctions sont des gens de
qualité
il ya sept cette espèce de d'étranges
choses où d'étranges réalité qui fait
que des femmes et des hommes de qualité
avec le souci du bien public
sans dans une organisation qui les
empêche de faire leur travail et cette
organisation elle vient de quoi penser
très très bien et depuis le temps et
quant à moi j'ai dit ça depuis longtemps
elle vient de ce que on a des systèmes
de recrutement qui ne sont pas les bons
je voudrais qu'on prenne exemple qu'on
réfléchisse à ce que fait l'armée
l'armée a réfléchi ces bons l'ont pas
mis longtemps à mettre au point un
système de recrutement qui fait que les
recrutements pour les postes de
responsabilité sont pas 20 ans ils se
font à 35 ans quand on a vu ce que la
femme ou l'homme qui à qui on va confier
ses responsabilités savait faire avec
des hommes de la réalité humaine s'il
était capable de les entraîner et ça
n'est pas seulement le diplôme à
l'entrée et c'est pourquoi le cette
rupture dont vous parlez entre l'état et
la société
elle est désespérante parce que
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui vient des
classes des femmes et des hommes qui
n'ont pas des situations beau rob
mirobolantes qui travaillent et qui sont
salariés parfois qui sont chômeurs
quelle chanson till d'entrée ou de
rejoindre les responsabilités les plus
importantes voulez la vérité
presqu'aucune parce que on a un système
de recrutement qui en réalité fait que
ce sont les mêmes à 20 ans vous à 22 ans
qui se trouve
qu'ils se trouvent repérez qui se trouve
reçu oui et qui pour toute leur vie vont
avoir ses responsabilités est ce que
vous appelez le corps préfectoral e coy
les corps les camps dans la société
française les corps qu'est ce que c'est
comme organisation et encore une fois
c'est des gens il vient qu'est ce que
c'est comme organisation c'est que vous
réussissiez ou pas dans votre fonction
vous êtes protégé jusqu'à un dernier
jour de votre travail
avis à savez vous combien il y à de
hauts fonctionnaires et de très hauts
fonctionnaires qui sont comme on dit au
placard c'est à dire dont été enlevés de
l'exercice de la responsabilité
oui et qui ont été mis dans une gâche
common brive est aujourd'hui pour les
protéger même s'il ne rendent plus le
service qu'on attend d'eux il y en a
plusieurs centaines peut-être n'arrive
aux milliers alors que cdc des gens des
femmes et des hommes qui ont des
capacités des aptitudes
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne les utilise pas
à soutenir la société française tous les
problèmes qui se posent sur le terrain
pourquoi ne les y envoie ton pas et
c'est cette logique corporatiste corps
corporatiste défense d'un corps et pas
défense des fonctions qui est visé
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement qu'il
faut rebâtir reconstruire
oui reconstruire françois bayrou un
grand désordre politique aussi vous le
constatez grand désordre à gauche grand
désordre pardon mais grand désordre eau
l air grand désordre à la république en
marche
le modem sa faune qui y a comme modèle
que ça va bien et puis le rassemblement
national même chose même chose
finalement
il ya deux parties qui fonctionne
françois bayrou les régionales eric
dupond moretti et gérald darmanin n'ont
ils pas autre chose à faire que d'aller
en campagne électorale combattre et
marine le pen et xavier bertrand
réflexion très rapide sur wii on leur a
assez reproché d'être coupé du terrain
oui de n'avoir jamais été élu de travaux
chez à gérald darmanin non mais reproche
à eric dupond moretti et un autre
à d'autres on a reproché au président de
la république alors ils vont s'enraciner
au contact des citoyens des électeurs
bon c'est une c'est une ligne qui a été
choisi et et dont je comprends
l'inspiration mais ma réflexion ça n'est
pas celle là
alors allez-y c'est là qu'est née devant
un om entre sens absolu contre lequel je
me suis battu et rebattu et ont
d'ailleurs battu ce contresens et
celui-ci on confond les élections
locales et les élections nationales
une élection locale c'est fait pour
bâtir une majorité diverses pour
soutenir un projet pour une région où
pour une commune pour une ville et la
loi de cette de cette élection c'est le
rassemblement qu'est ce qu'on vient
raconter des gens qui étaient ensemble
et dont on prétendrait qu'ils n'ont plus
jamais à se parler
le sectarisme un produit dans des
élections qui sont des élections qui
n'auront où l'on trouve tant ce
sectarisme soyons car tout part que les
républicains par exemple oui fable
devait choisir entre la république en
marche et le rassemblement national sont
en voie de disparition à cause de ce
séisme ça vous le verrez les historiens
verront mais surtout pas que ce que je
sais c'est que prétendre oui qu'on n'a
rien à voir ensemble alors qu'on est
concomitant soit avec l air soit avec
d'anciens responsables sociaux
démocrates du parti socialiste qu'on
aurait rien à construire
alors que vous auriez bien du mal si
vous preniez un microscope à trouver la
différence entre la gestion d'un
président de région de droite d'un
président de région du centre d'un
président de région de gauche et même
des présidents de région d'autres
d'autres inspirations le
temps vous êtes alors affronter
confronter à la réalité locale
vous prenez des décisions qui sont des
décisions de bon sens plus ou moins
ambitieuse plus ou moins généreuse mais
en tout état de cause ces politiques là
qui sont conduites au niveau local ce
sont des politiques qui n'ont rien à
voir avec la carte de parti que vous
avez dans la poche
où sont donc ça veut dire qu'il est
ridicule de prétendre qu'on va des
calques et toute la politique nationale
avec les affrontements qu'on connaît qui
sont là encore stupide dont mais
confusion confusion la république en
marche qui d'un côté un soutien en
région provence alpes côte d'azur
un candidat a l'air dans les hauts de
france qui ne soutient pas un candidat
qui n'est plus l air mais qui était au
président de la république dans la
région de vous essayer de décrire des
choses je cite décrire la confusion
difficile
non vous vous soulignez la confusion oui
alors qu'on peut essayer de clarifier et
d'éclairer les choses alors on va le
faire il ya six ans dans les hauts de
france
oui mon bac à toutes les forces
politiques extérieures à l'extrême
droite on fait ce qu'il faut et y
compris des sacrifices avec i'm négation
pour faire élire un candidat de remplace
de rassemblement souhaité estrosi d'un
côté xavier bertrand de l'autre oui et
il se trouve que aujourd'hui dans un cas
comme dans l'autre le parti politique
qui les soutenaient dit nous interdisons
toute alliance avec ce qu'ils nous ont
fait élire
même s'ils font partie de la majorité et
bien pour moi je trouve ça stupide si
j'avais été président de région mais je
suis maire c'est à peu près la wii à peu
près la même chose j'aurais dit mesdames
et messieurs des appareils politiques
vous êtes très sympathique je vous aime
beaucoup mais je vais construire pour ma
région et pour ma ville
la majorité la plus large et je veux que
dans ma majorité puisque j'appartiens à
vos rangs y ait des gens de l'opposition
mais je veux aussi des gens de la
majorité parce qu'on a besoin
pour être défendus dans les décisions
gouvernementales de gens qui est cette
sensibilité une région ou une ville
mérite qu'on se rassemble et qu'on
essaie de trouver ce qui a de plus
comment dire de plus fédérateur pour
l'avenir des citoyens à qui vont vous
être confiées
c'est ça qui devrait être la ligne on
l'a ratée aux municipales vous souvenez
que je me suis beaucoup battu sur ce
sujet oui alors à pau on va vous êtes
bourque on a su le faire au sujet et
vous n'avez pas été entendu vous êtes
venu sur la propreté
vous êtes battus sur jean jacques
bourdin jeux s'enchaînent pour le vote
par correspondance sur le doublement du
plan de relance pour les joueurs
n'avaient pas été entendus et bien vous
vous trompez haut sur au moins deux de
ces sujets aborda korb alors sur le plan
de relance excusez moi de dire ça oui
le président de la république peut-être
vous n'avez pas fait attention
oui est allé à bruxelles oui et à 10 et
non de la france qu'il fallait un
nouveau plan de relance
oui et bien excuser moi de dire ça n'est
pas une défaite c'est une victoire
bon d'accord quant à la proportionnelle
vous dites que vous êtes battus vous
vous êtes pas arriver qu'est ce que vous
en savez moi je crois venus les mois qui
viennent y arriver je vous ai vus
arriver je crois que les mois qui
viennent oui vont obliger le président
de la république s'il se représente a
présenté un nouveau visage du pouvoir
dans son rapport avec les citoyens et
que quand on s'interroge pour savoir
comment changer le rapport avec des
citoyens
alors vous allez voir même serein
conditions de votre soutien ont
d'ailleurs accusé de soutenir la
présidentielle soutenir s'il se
représente je ferai tout ce que je peux
pour l'aider dans vous soutiendrez et
donc moi je vous dis vous soutiendrez
vous le soutiendrez vous vous savez bien
ce que vous présentez quoi il combat il
perdu c'est que ben peut-être vous
n'avez pas le calendrier en tête et moi
je crois peut-être je me trompe
on verra je crois que c'est une
nécessité pour changer le climat
politique dans ce pays une vie voyez je
voyais oui qu'est-ce que c'est le climat
politique et je valais je vais livrer un
contre tous oui tous unis contre un et
moi je crois que pour vous
regardez la france dans les années qui
viennent il va falloir dépasser ce 1
contre tous et être capable de faire
vivre et travailler ensemble des gens
différents
alors un mot la mise en examen de marine
le pen dans l' enquête sur le
détournement des deux fonds européens au
profit du rassemblement national
vous aviez dit ici ici même tout le
monde est mise en examen ou à peu près
dans la vie politique française je me
souviens est-ce qu'elle pourrait être
privé prévoyez de d'être candidate non
je ne crois pas de le voir ressurgir ces
affaires perpétuellement lorsque les
échéances électorales avec et violation
du secret de l'instruction sans doute
fait y'a qu'ça en france avec le lorsque
les échéances électorales viennent ça
laisse interrogatif sur la manière dont
ces ses coups de théâtre où ses mises en
scène médiatico policière et justice
sont organisés s'est organisé pour vous
soit en tout cas ces révélations sentent
c'est décidé non je dis pas guidé
peut-être n'y a pas une main noire mais
je vois bien que à chaque élection ces
affaires reviennent françois bayrou jour
et terminer avec l'avenir démocratique
démographique de la france qui n'est
plus assurée il manquerait quarante à
cinquante mille naissances par an pour
assurer le renouvellement des
générations
alors vous faites des propositions il
faut une natalité forte et n'oublions
pas plus se reposent plus fin que tout
repose en france sur la solidarité la
fessée absolument l'argument oui de la
réflexion que vous évoquez nous sommes
un pays le seul dans le monde
oui qui a choisi un modèle de société un
contrat social qui fait que la totalité
des soutiens et des aides
oui les retraites bien entendu mais
l'éducation la santé la totalité des
soutiens et des aides repose sur les
actifs donc si le nombre d'actifs se
réduit alors je vous le dis il n'y a
aucune possibilité de faire autrement
les aides le contrat social le soutien
lors la solidarité baisse sur deux
solutions encourager les naissances
évidemment
l'enjeu c'est pas moi augmenter les
allocations familiales mais c'est en
tout cas on a touché aux allocations
familiales on s'est trompé on s'est
trompé
vous parlez des conditions de ressources
oui je parle de ce qui a été fait par le
gouvernement de françois hollande on
s'est trompé on s'est trompé pour
revenir là dessus
oui en tout cas il faut repenser le
système de soutien se met le soutien
s'est pas seulement des allocations
c'est oui bien sûr l'accueil à la petite
enfance et les crèches les assistantes
maternelles le logement l'emploi
l'ambiance dit oui les mères de famille
que ça n'est pas parce qu'elles ont des
enfants que leur carrière vont être
ralentie et offert hier aux carrières
des femmes si la france a eu plus
d'enfants que les autres pays en europe
c'est parce que la situation des femmes
au travail
il était plus accepter ou soutenu et
c'est ça la vérité donc vous voyez que
ce que nous évoquons là c'est en réalité
la même chose que les interviews que
nous avons eus ensemble sur
l'effondrement de l'appareil productif
de la france industrielle agricole c'est
pareil nous sommes un pays qui est fondé
sur la solidarité
et s'il n'y a plus assez de gens pour
porter la solidarité ou assez de
ressources pour financer la solidarité
alors elle va s'effondrer elle va
s'effondrer et l'immigration
l'immigration la france doit accueillir
des personnes d'autres pays mais vous
dites dans des proportions raisonnables
non je pense que ceux qui imaginent ont
la grinta seulement france l'allemagne a
accepté un million d'immigrés examen
d'un seul coup oui venant pour
l'essentiel de syrie dans une de ces
périodes de crise passion c'est le
patronat allemand qui avait demandé sa
une grande déclaration au début de
l'année vient en dix ans on a besoin
d'un million
deux personnes de plus moi je crois que
ça n'est pas une solution
en tout cas évidemment ça peut aider
dans des moments critiques
mais lorsque vous introduisez des
communautés importantes oui nombreuses
dans une société déjà fragile
alors ça fait des chocs culturels qui
les traits ils font mieux contrôler
l'immigration et il faut en tout cas
faire ce qu'il faut pour que septième
pour que des migrations ne soit pas un
perpétuel irritant de la société
française avec toujours les mêmes mots
toujours les mêmes chiffres sans qu'on
sache aujourd'hui comment reconduire
parce que c'est ça la question
il ya des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de personnes qu'on a identifié
comme étant en situation illégale et
qu'on ne sait pas reconduire parce que
les pays d'où ils viennent ne les
veulent pas ne les accepte pas y compris
en europe
merci françois bayrou d'être venu nous
voir ce matin vers 6 à vous sur rmc et
sur bfm tv